you um have announced a cabinet office
investigation into the claims made by
nusrat ghani do you believe her claims
or do you believe your chief whip as
they can't both be right look thank you
very much we take these allegations
extremely seriously i took them very
seriously when they were raised with me
18 months ago very glad there's an
investigation
taking place now i can't say more really
about it but what i can say is i'm here
in milton keynes university hospital
focusing on what i think is one of the
biggest issues facing the the country
and something that people really want us
to fix and that is how we come out of
covid not just with our economy open
more open than any other society economy
in europe but how we deal now with the
covid backlogs particularly in
healthcare
six million people waiting for for
treatments uh that number i've got to
tell people sadly is gonna rise it's
gonna keep it's gonna go up so we've got
to use absolutely everything in our
toolbox to fix the backlogs
investment massive investment that we're
making but also new technology and so
here at milton keynes university
hospital i've been looking at robotic
surgery i've got some some footage of
that that can help to speed up
procedures it can uh protect patients
can give them better outcomes but also
enable surgeons to do more and a huge
numbers of people are waiting uh for
those types of procedure i was going to
ask about
very briefly what we're doing just
quickly in addition to what we're doing
on on diagnostics hubs and of course on
the massive investments that we're
making in staff back on those right
connie do you believe that mark spencer
can stay in his job while this
investigation is going on i think really
you we
just get back to the key point
this is something i take personally
extremely seriously i took it very
seriously 18 months ago we must wait and
see what the
investigation produces but if i can just
go back uh by your leave uh to what
we're doing here
this is
believe me a problem that we need to
to fix and i do think that there
probably isn't a family in the in the
country that hasn't
doesn't know somebody who's had their
their treatment delayed because of was
because of kovid
across the country millions of people
didn't come forward for treatments we
have people waiting for
for cancer treatments for all sorts of
things
for surgery we have to fix it so on the
cover the restriction
restrictions though diagnostics uh
community diagnostics hubs robotic
surgery
drive cancer screening all those types
of things we're doing but above all you
need to make the investment
in the staff forty four thousand okay
well more people in the sticking on
coverage
and that
we've still got some restrictions
testing requirements on on travel for
covid what what has anything been
decided on what the future of that will
be so
very important point we have
thanks to the tough decisions the the
big calls that we made and and i think
most people would agree that we got the
big calls right in uh in this terrible
struggle against against covid uh
we have the most open economy and and
society in europe and although we have
to be cautious
we are now moving through
uh
the omicron wave and you can see the
figures are starting to get better so
what we're doing on on travel
to show that this country is is open for
business open for travelers you will see
uh changes so that people arriving no
longer uh have to take uh have to take
tests if they've been vaccinated if
they've been double vaccinated it's a
big week for you the sugray report is
due out can you guarantee that no more
embarrassing allegations about alleged
breaches of lockdown
within downing street will come out
before that report is published what i
can guarantee is that this government is
focused
100 percent on dealing with
the big problems that we have but on the
sue grey report
do you think change is now inevitable in
downing street after that report has
come out specifically on the sugree
report i know that you know i personally
understand people want to ask questions
about that i think you you've got to
wait for for that to come out but what i
will say this government is focused on
the stuff that i think people want us to
focus on and
we've come through covid faster than
most other european countries thanks to
some of the decisions we we took thanks
to our incredible nhs thanks to what
they did with the booster rollout and uh
the unbelievable work that they did and
and the british people
who who followed the advice and have
delivered the result that we're in but
what we've got to do now is look at all
the problems that kovid has helped to
create
the
particularly the backlogs in
in the courts
and one of those big problems i guess is
around cost of living as well correct
can you guarantee that national
insurance will go up in april this year
as planned
what we've got to do is look at all the
ways we can address cost of living for
that doesn't sound like a guarantee of
national insurance
all we can do to address the cost of
living issues for people so it's it's
the cost of
fuel uh tax rise could be shelved i'm
sure it's making sure that we uh we deal
with uh inflation by getting people into
work dealing with problems in the supply
chains getting people off welfare into
work helping to get our economy moving
smoothly again so no guarantee of that
tax rights on just on on that specific
issue
look at where we are look at what we're
investing in and don't forget that what
i think is the the number one priority
for people in this country it is you
know the nhs has done an amazing job but
it has been under terrific strength but
on the tax rise can you guarantee that
that national insurance will go up what
i'm saying this is what i'm saying what
i'm telling you is we've got to put that
money in we've got to make that
investment in our nhs
we've just been looking at fantastic
robotic
surgery robotic assisted surgery made in
cambridge an amazing british development
will that will that money come through a
national insurance rise though prime
minister
those machines are not cheap uh 44
thousand more staff in our nhs will the
money come through our national
insurance rise there were last year
those are that guaranteed now the
national insurance people what i'm
telling people is that if you want to
fund our fantastic nhs we have to pay
for it and and this government is
determined to do so and just very
finally another big issue is obviously
what's happening in ukraine uh the uk
has taken some stuff out of the embassy
in kiev the eu has not do we know
something that the eu doesn't why are we
taking staff out are you concerned about
what might happen next well first of all
i want to thank our i want to thank
melinda our ambassador in uh in kiev uh
i want to thank our wonderful staff
there they've done an outstanding job in
a very difficult time
and we do think it prudent to make some
changes now the intelligence is very
clear that there are 60 russian battle
groups about six russian battle groups
on the borders of of ukraine uh the plan
for a lightning war that could take out
kiev is one that everybody
can see
we need to make it very clear to
the kremlin to russia that that would be
a disastrous step and so what we're
saying is that the uk is leading on
creating the package of economic
sanctions
working with our partners um around the
world and i'll be talking to to them
this afternoon this evening uh talking
to to to colleagues in other capitals
and in washington
uh but we also
need to get over the message
that
invading ukraine from a from a russian
perspective
is going to be a painful violent and
bloody
business and i think it's very important
that people in russia
understand that this could be a new
chechnya i've been to to ukraine several
times i've i i know uh the people of
that country a bit and my judgment is
that they will fight and really that is
not the way the world should be going
and i hope that
they understand that in the in the
kremlin but it's the job of the uk to
make sure that our friends and partners
around the world particularly in europe
you mentioned europe also understand
that we get ready a tough enough package
of of sanctions that sounds like you
think a russian invasion of ukraine
could happen and could be imminent
look i've got
to tell you that i think that the
uh intelligence is is pretty gloomy on
this point there is certainly a a large
uh
very very large
uh array of russian forces
and we have to take the necessary steps
i don't think it's in by any means
inevitable now i think that sense can
still prevail but the uk is in the lead
in creating that package of economic
sanctions uh stiffening the uh the
helping to stiffen the resistance of uh
of our ukrainian friends
as you know with
defensive weaponry that we're supplying
and making it clear that we stand fully
foursquare
with the people of ukraine and that we
support the
sovereign
integrity of of ukraine and we do
but we also need to get over to to
russia
that any invasion any incursion
of any kind
of any dimension
into ukraine is not going to be a
cost-free business uh it is not going to
be a uh
it will there will be casualties and i
think that people in russia need to
understand that it could be that their
new chechnya